endemic when it comes to covid the word
is being thrown around by seemingly
everyone endemic endemic endemic
but what does it actually mean and is
kovit already endemic if not will it
ever be and what does it mean for a much
awaited return to normal i'm going to
share three key factors that'll help us
understand how we get to an endemic
state and i'll answer those questions
along the way let's dive in
something we should get out of the way
now is that endemicity doesn't actually
mark the end of covid or a clean-cut end
to the pandemic and while we're defining
things pandemic means that there are
large outbreaks in multiple continents
but endemic is just another stage of our
life with any virus including the one
that causes covid now that we have that
clear let's check the dictionary to
understand what endemic actually means
persisting in a population or region
generally having settled to a relatively
constant rate of occurrence huh okay so
this definition is a little wordy but it
suggests that a disease that is endemic
occurs regularly and in a certain
population or region let's start with
regularly our first key factor in
understanding endemic what the
definition is saying is that there needs
to be a regular rate of infection or
baseline for a disease to be endemic as
you can see that hasn't been the case
for covid knowing what the steady state
of a disease looks like is really
important for establishing endemicity
that's because it allows experts to
identify whether cases are higher than
usual meaning there's an outbreak or an
epidemic going on even when a disease is
endemic there can still be surges in
cases because it isn't gone its presence
is just more predictable so how long is
it going to be until we figure out what
that steady predictable state or
baseline is for covid to answer that
question i spoke with lisa lee an
infectious disease epidemiologist at
virginia tech
there is no hard and test rule it's not
after x number of months it's important
to remember that what we expect or will
tolerate around the number of cases also
varies wait what we'll tolerate will
vary but how that brings us to our
second factor in understanding endemic
location endemic isn't one size fits all
that's in part because
different places have different
political and social will and capacity
public health capacity to manage a
disease to
respond in a timely manner that kind of
thing responding in a timely manner
depends on access to drugs tests and
vaccines plus healthcare capacity that
differs depending on where you are with
covid we can end up in a situation where
it's endemic or stable in some places
but causing persistent outbreaks in
others and there's another wrinkle like
those definitions said endemic diseases
occur in a certain population or region
as long as covit is raging worldwide
instead of only in certain places then
we technically haven't reached
endemicity that's because infections in
one place can complicate efforts to
contain the virus in others
that's what happened with omicron every
time the virus transmits we know it gets
a little
smarter in the sense that it can create
variants to become more
contagious or more lethal it has done
both of those things getting to an
endemic state is kind of like a tug of
war between us and the virus that causes
covet but that tug of war isn't just
about regularity location or viral
evolution endemicity also has to do with
how much social disruption and death
we're willing to accept in other words
it has to do with us and our own
perception of risk there needs to be a
mental shift which is our third key
factor in understanding endemic flu for
example can kill thousands of people
every year more in a particularly bad
one and we have
generally come to the conclusion that
that is something we can live with now
that doesn't minimize of course the the
pain and suffering of people who do lose
their loved ones to influenza but it is
something that you've said okay this is
about the background weight rate we're
willing to tolerate we don't know yet
what that background rate is for covid
but in certain parts of the world our
perception of covert risk is shifting
thanks to vaccines and new antivirals
among people who are vaccinated the risk
of ending up in the hospital is pretty
low in the u.s mass mandates are ending
governments are easing restrictions and
increasingly social distancing seems a
thing of the past that represents a
mental shift towards endemicity so what
does all this mean for our much awaited
return to normal omicron may have
offered us a preview of our covet future
we were starting to feel like we were
getting back to normal when it emerged
and then boom a surge that means back to
normal won't look like a return to 2019
but rather something new we'll have to
stay vigilant about what variants are
out there and how well our vaccines and
drugs work against them maybe covet will
be seasonal like the flu or maybe it'll
be an all-year affair we just don't know
yet it's important to remember that
whatever endemicity ends up looking like
people will still get really sick and
some people will still die i think the
biggest misconception people have about
what endemic means it's kind of a safe
level endemicity is not the end of covid
it just means it's more predictable and
whatever case levels we tolerate might
differ by location based on our medical
resources and our collective comfort
level with risk
how are you adjusting to our new copic
normal let me know in the comments and
don't forget to hit subscribe thanks for
watching i gracias
[Music]